someone's got a future as a red carpet
reporter and that's brie bella's
daughter she's amazing it's
incredible well
i enjoy myself and i think everybody
enjoys me interviewing them what about
you
[Music]
yup that's wwe star brie bella's
four-year-old birdie stealing the show
and the mike in a backstage interview
with wwe hall of famer mark henry
can you introduce me to your brother
what's your brother's name
he's a wild man
every day she's doing something
different and i'm just like oh my gosh
please don't stop doing this it's so
cute the whole family attended the st
patrick's slam edition of aew dynamite
to show support for bree's hubby and
father to their children brian danielson
and reporter birdie doesn't let dad get
too far without throwing a question or
two his way
and while she's at it she pulls her baby
brother buddy over for a chat but that's
not all from these adorable siblings
watch buddy's excitement as he catches a
glimpse of his pro wrestler dad on
screen
as for brian he's loving fatherhood he
shared a sweet post about his kiddos
showing support for him in the ring
writing being a dad to these two is the
most rewarding experience i could ask
for and he's definitely getting lots of
time to enjoy parenting ahead of the
super bowl last month bree and nikki
bella had a sister's night out mom's
gone wild well who is babysitting while
moms are having the mom's gone wild
night daddy's daddy's daddy
e.t caught up with the twins last year
where they gushed about being moms and
brie revealed whether she thinks there's
a chance her kids might follow in her
wrestling footsteps so buddy
a restaurant
he's so strong and it's funny because
when you change his diaper he sometimes
will put an arm bar on you and it makes
brian so proud he's like he already
knows how to do an arm bar i'm like well
it's in his blood
but um he definitely like
he's very fearless and he just
is strong and he anytime like he'll
headbutt things or like he'll pinch his
fingers and he doesn't cry he almost
gets like mad that he pinched his
fingers and i look at him and i'm like
he's a wrestler in the making so i feel
like
no matter what birdie and buddy will
have some type of interest in wrestling
just because of brian and i
it makes me nervous because you do see
the injuries and you know how long
you're on the road for and you know it's
just it's a tough industry yeah but if
it's what they whatever they want to do
i'm going to support so if they want to
be restless i'll support that and i do
there's a part of me
and i know it's because like as a woman
to see like my daughter like kind of
follow my footsteps kind of makes me
like gives me goosebumps and i i just
would be proud because it's like wow she
was really inspired by me and that's
really neat
[Music]
you